okay stop everything in this reality
eats so fast that it rarely gives us
time to slow down and think about the
biggest questions so stop what you're
doing and buckle in for a minute first
of all why does this reality exist are
we here to explore play rise to some
sort of a grand challenge this adventure
and consciousness feels like a
transcendent gift how do we architect
our social fabric to be most conducive
for unleashing our unique gifts second
of all what made
reality could it be that we ourselves
are the creators and have simply
forgotten why do we anthropomorphize our
creator why do we call this assimilation
what are we praying to when every choice
we make directly affects our life
trajectory could we ourselves be not
only the authors of our own destinies
but also the authors of this grand human
experiment testing our ability to
understand ourselves lastly what is your
unique gifts what contribution do you
want to have in this world there are
infinite combinations but there is
something uniquely inside of you that
only you can express how can you uncover
that how can you actualize that explore
play until you find what lights the fire
under your ass
remember to stop more often contemplate
these biggest questions why does this
reality exist
what made this reality what is your
unique gift unleash yourself and each
other most fully into our world and
don't forget to hold the childlike are
from every moment of life
[Music]